There's a new hierarchy and tone and
it's the hierarchy of Silicon Valley to
the people who run these companies.
There is an astonishing sense of power,
but in the last 12 months there's been a
realization that as they say in the
spiderman movies with great power comes
great responsibility and a great deal of
trouble too if you don't know how to
manage that responsibility.
Of course,
Neil,
most of those,
if probably all,
almost all of those silicon valley
Internet billionaires would have
preferred Hillary Clinton of compressed
the United States and she didn't.
So to their utter horror,
and it really was,
it was really kind of fascinating to
watch up close.
They found that the network platforms
they'd created could be used to achieve
the opposite of what they had intended.
It was not the Clinton administration,
the Clinton campaign that knew how to
use facebook to target advertising in
order to secure the swing states.
It was the trump campaign.
It was Steve Bannon and jared Kushner,
not to mention Russian intelligence,
but we are in the midst of a great
expose a,
which is not over,
that is going to reveal the extent to
which trump campaign in a large way and
the Russian intelligence network in a
small way used facebook and to a lesser
extent,
other platforms to achieve victory in
the 2016 presidential election.
And I argue in the book,
and I stand by it,
that Donald Trump would not be president
today if there had not been facebook and
twitter and the other platforms that
were used,
uh,
in a conventional,
traditional American election campaign,
he would have been defeated because he
would've been out spent Hillary Clinton
outspent Donald Trump two to one more
than two to one,
uh,
on standard cable and terrestrial
television advertising,
he would have lost.
So this was a hugely significant moment
in American political history.
I still don't think people realize the
extent to which it depended on the use
of facebook in particular.